all right mike yes mike where'd you grow
up where are you from originally i grew
up in chino hills um i was born in
corona hospital
tell me about your family
my mom's a professor of child um
development
my dad's a mechanical engineer for
anheuser-busch or they were they're both
retired now
sounds like a good home life at home
yeah i had a really good home life
no abuse nothing like nothing crazy
going on no no abuse um nothing crazy
any addicts in your family um my
biological father is an addict but i
didn't grow up around him um my dad
adopted me when i was in sixth grade
and um yeah
when did drugs come into your life
around the age of nine or ten oh early
yeah i started smoking weed around nine
or ten i have a brother that's 10 years
older than me and
um he got me
stoned so i wouldn't tell mom and dad
that he was getting stoned
and from that point on i would go out of
my way to try to catch him getting high
so i could get high too
and then he just progressed from there
did he end up having a problem as well
with drugs no he actually he had no
issues at all you have a harder time
putting it down um yeah
yeah i i excelled and he stuck with
um
alcohol and pot i mean he still drinks
but not not alcoholically yeah
and did it affect your
education um no i i have a bachelor's
degree in business um
i i didn't have a problem with drugs
until
i started doing heroin i had broken my
leg about 15 years ago
and the doctor prescribed me 60 narcos
with 10 refills every two weeks so i was
getting 600 narcos every two weeks
and then when they cut me off i just
started doing whatever i could to so i
wouldn't get sick
and um i started doing heroin and then i
mean it just slowly my life kind of i
threw everything away from that point on
um i was a loan officer for eight years
for a mortgage company um i was making
close to a quarter million dollars a
year uh legally um
and i at the time i i didn't know about
like real estate cycles and i didn't
think that um i thought that's how i was
going to live forever it was just going
to continue to make that paycheck
and when the housing market crashed my
bills were at 65 000
and i made 42 000 that year and i ended
up spending it on just my lifestyle and
not really my bills so i filed
bankruptcy and um my life's just kind of
slowly deteriorated since then
you've been homeless yes um yeah i was
homeless my first time in santa ana
actually um
in my i lived in this apartment complex
in santa ana and they have these
little storages above the parking
structure
and um my wife and i we were staying in
there
in the parking structure because we
could climb out of it and put a lock on
it during the day and keep our stuff
secure and then
run around town and do whatever we
needed and then come back
as you
but i it was it was in the apartment
complex that actually i used to live in
but as you were
progressing into your addiction did you
see your life
unraveling um yes like
did you did you realize what was what
you were doing and
could you put the brakes on it or no i
mean i didn't put the brake i mean i've
i've wanted to put the brakes on it ever
since i started
but i i just i don't i mean i
um
once i started
doing crime and stuff like that um i
started stealing to support my habit
and then i got arrested for
uh grand theft
and then my life i mean from that point
on i couldn't get bonded by the state
any longer so i couldn't go back into
doing loans um so i mean i just started
stealing more and then going to jail
i was in and out of jail and then
this last time when i was out
i started manufacturing ghost guns
and that that supported
my my habit and my lifestyle for a while
until um
it's not registered it doesn't have any
serial number on that you can order them
online and just put them together
and then um i finally got it caught up
with that and um
i was i just did 13 months and i was
released out of jail about three four
months ago
and i was just homeless until um the
tiny homes let me start staying there
and that was just a couple weeks ago
but this criminal behavior
is it's not in your nature
no no it's all from my addiction yeah
what do you what do you think most
people don't understand about
what you're going through with drugs
just how difficult like how much time
and effort you have to put into it it
it it takes everything that you love
you
your love ends up going into the drug
and um
and it takes away everything else that
you love
um
right i've lost my wife i've lost my
kids my family doesn't like talking to
me
um
and i mean i was really close with my
family my whole life
um i mean i'm a mama's boy and my mom
doesn't the only reason my mom even
talks to me now is because she has my
son
and i i call every saturday and sunday
and i spend an hour on the phone with my
son and she and she
she has to observe um the phone call
but other than that i mean she doesn't
want anything to do with me same thing
with my dad and i mean i don't blame
them i've stolen from them i've used
them
and
yeah i really don't blame them not not
the only family that i talk to anymore
is my uncle who lives in germany and
that's just because he has never spent
any time with me really he only knows me
through social media
like he knows the person that i used to
be
not the person that i've become
how is this it's gotta be hard for you
emotionally uh sure definitely just the
shame alone
yeah
especially with my kids um i missed the
relationship i had i've had with my kids
um
it hurts watching my mom
raise my son
um
luckily my daughter's with my wife um
or i mean soon to be my ex-wife she left
me this time around when i was in jail
i haven't talked to her since last june
um
yeah she moved back in with her parents
when she we we had gotten arrested
together we were in laguna i was taking
her out to dinner
and um
and we both had gotten arrested she had
a probation warrant
and so she went in just for a couple
months and i i had five glocks on me and
40 grams of fentanyl
so
i ended up
doing 13 months total
and yeah and this time around um
i mean the only thing i had left when i
went got arrested was my wife
um her her parents had our daughter
and my parents had our son
you
still seem to have your common sense
about you and your wits you you're
you're it seems like the the real mic is
still inside you all right thank you i
appreciate that but you
are also
pulled away by
by the addiction for sure i i have
really good skills um i mean i i've
worked my whole life
with through my addiction i mean i've
always been on some kind of substance
whether it was hallucinogens or i was a
real bad alcoholic for a long time
um
i mean with alcohol i just replaced it
with heroin
um i always replaced it with something
like it was from pot to cocaine
cocaine to alcohol
cocaine and alcohol to heroin
and now fentanyl and now fentanyl um
and i mean i want nothing more
than to give up my habit and spend the
rest of my life trying to help people
like me
like that that's my ultimate goal
it's the only way i feel like that
i can make my kids proud of of me
because i've been such a disappointment
to them
yeah it almost makes the problem worse
for you because you're a disappointment
to your family your kids yeah
everyone around around and around you
probably have no friends now yeah
i mean the only friend i really have
left is um
is is my my friend cameron i think you
interviewed him as well
yeah and that's because he's in his
addiction as well
um
and we both have the same goal as to
wanting to help others
as we if we clean up but
it's just words right now i mean
i i want nothing more than to put into
action but it's just
it's hard like to
to go through the sickness and and to
detox the drug
and
i mean it's just a
cycle over and over again i don't know
why i do it but i do
i do whatever i can to feed that habit
and i i put everything that i care about
and i love on the back backhand
like
i just don't get it
what do you do for money now
um anything possible
um
whatever i need to
stealing is my main thing um
i i mean i don't steal from people
it's a big thing of mine like i don't
wanna i would never wanna steal from
somebody that's struggling like me
but um i have no problem stealing from
stores so i'm really good at it too
um
i mean i say that but i also have
i i believe seven felonies because of
ceiling
but compared to what i've gotten away
with um i mean there's no comparison
but this isn't somebody that i would
have ever been if i didn't touch heroin
um
yeah
are you adhd yes
you didn't take long to answer that no
yeah real
tension disorder i see a strong
connection between adhd
people and
these addictions that are just
so overpowering that they can't
yeah because i mean looking back in my
life um i've always been an addict
before the drug it was it was always
something i mean whether it was my
hobbies to begin with and
to start off with and then it was work
i've always
done everything addictively
um
which i i can see being very helpful i
mean that's why i was so successful in
the past um
because i give my all to whatever it is
i do
um i mean it's just
heroin and fentanyl takes everything
like it takes all of your energy it
takes all of your effort to support your
habit
i mean if you're rich i i there's i
don't really see a problem with it like
if you're rich and you could support
your habit and
and it doesn't take away from
your life
then i mean then that's what you want to
do but
if you don't have that you're you have
to dedicate everything you are
to support your habit
and it's going to take everything from
you
um
i mean that's just what it does i've
seen it over and over and over again
i've seen the best families fall apart
because of it
i've seen the most successful people
on the streets um
and it's just
yeah it's it's sad
what emotions do you go through you get
depressed i'm sure for sure
um
yeah i
definitely depressed i'm
it's not easy to throw away everything
that you love
for something that you
you you
don't want to do
how old are you i'm 40. you're 40. yeah
is there any chance that you could like
when you go to jail you get
you get forced to be clean right yeah
and when you came out of a
a jail stand you
is there any way my goal in jail was to
stay clean and then but just going
through the depression of my wife
leaving me
getting the adoption papers from my my
parents they want to adopt my son now um
they already have custody um
but now they want to adopt my son
but if you were able to get clean i'm
sure they would give you your son back
if you
yeah stay clean for a long time for sure
i'd have to go through a process of
they'd have to earn their my trust back
of course yeah i'm not saying it would
happen instantly but all i'm saying is
like if you were able to replace
your opiate addiction with a career or
something that you were really into
motivated by
yeah
and i know that's it
they always say that that they they miss
the real michael
yeah that's always
what i hear from them
[Music]
my dad my dad um
i mean he was a mechanical engineer for
anheuser-busch but when he retired he
started doing real estate investing
and i was a loan officer so i mean
i've helped my dad
build um
what he has
and like he just he doesn't get like why
like why i can't put it down
i don't either
i mean
i've done drugs my whole life and like
nothing ever took me away from
like my my lifestyle was all i always
use drugs purposefully
whether it was spiritually
or
to
have fun like that night with a group of
people
whatever it was i always did it
purposefully
but when i started doing heroin it
became selfishly
it became just to just to feed my habit
like just to
and it's such such an illusion like it
it gets a grasp you and you just you
don't see everything going like throwing
away and all of a sudden you just have
nothing
and then you get to a point where you
don't know where to start
um
nobody trusts you nobody wants to help
you you've thrown all of your bridges
away
and
you you're almost content in your
depression and your in your lifestyle
you get used to it
and it
and
you kind of just fade away
you've lost your id and you've lost all
your finances and everything everything
yeah yeah
and you're surrounded by people that are
in a similar city in the same situation
and yeah i mean
nobody's helping anybody
what's your biggest fear
at this point
um
having my kids
see their homeless dad
their their nobody dad
um
not being a part of my kid's life
like i i didn't give my kids away i
threw him away
and
it sucks to even like to think that but
that's the truth
i gave my kids up for fentanyl
and
i hate myself for it
um
not only do i hate myself for it like
i don't give up the thing that i hate
doing
for the something that i love
and that that's the saddest part about
it
do you know anything about your your
dad's addiction
um my dad's
been a
a successful addict
thank you
um his whole life he
he's um
a union electrician who is your
biological dad yeah my biological father
uh he works for uh he's retired now but
he was worked for international
brotherhood of electrical workers his
whole life since my he was with my mom
um in fact they used to hide the my
dad's wages
so he wouldn't have to pay childs for it
and but he's always
had a job
done a career
speed was his drug of choice and i mean
he still uses today and
he doesn't really have an issue just
like with me i used to use
quite a bit of cocaine and alcohol when
i was successful in real estate and it
was never an issue
in fact it kind of helped me make money
um
it allowed me to open up when i needed
to it allowed me to focus when i needed
to and i just played that nobody saw saw
me because it was all on the phone so i
just had to play this
this role and as long as i could play
that role
money came in and i mean that's just how
my life was for a long time and then to
have fun with i i enjoyed using
hallucinogens that was my big thing
um i mean that's a lot for me for like
my spiritual practices and stuff i've
always
used hallucinogens um
so i mean that was never like an
addictive thing but
i don't even believe that i could use
those successfully anymore
because
because of my my use with fentanyl has
turned
like my my habit
addictively like in everything that i
use but in a negative way
whereas before i'd always
i'd used to enhance my life
not to throw it away
and and today i used to throw my life
away
unfortunately
what's your biggest regret
um
biggest regret
honestly
if i can turn my life around
if i if i could stop using
i don't really have any regrets
i look at it as an experience
and as long as
if i could turn this around
and turn it into something positive
there's nothing to regret
it's
it's all positive
in in the long run
but um
to get there
is the hard part is
if
if i ever do get there
um i mean i i don't know
because i'm not there now i'm not
i i haven't
started
cleaning up um
yeah i i have these wants and these
desires but i don't
put any action to it
but if i can
there's there's nothing to regret
i mean i i didn't do these things
because of the person that i am i did
these things to feed a habit to
i mean
i don't look at it as a negative thing
that i did i i did i i put my all
into something
and that's really what you should do
but
if you can
i mean it's such a trap
put your all into something positive
don't don't put it into something that
there's you don't get anything good out
of fentanyl there's nothing good about
it there's no reason to ever use it even
if you're dying of like you have some
terminal illness and you're dying and it
takes away the pain for someone
like it there's
[Music]
to outweigh the negative that it has is
there's no reason for it at all
like there's no nothing that i can see
positive out of it
like it doesn't help people at all it
just numbs you and then you throw
everything away and it's just
you have nothing
and you won't have anything until
you give it up
and that's if you can
i i haven't been able to
like regardless of how much i want to
i even i even had 13 months clean in
jail and i went right back to it when i
got out my depression just brought me
right back to it
i i believe if i got out and i
i wasn't on the street like if i if i
would have went straight into something
that i probably would have i mean at
least been successful while i was doing
it i don't know do you feel like mental
health is the real issue behind it for
sure there's definitely like depression
um yeah definitely
mental health
i mean that's what it all is it's not
stopping the drug it's
fixing the mental
state
because if you were if you were a sound
mind and inspired to do something with
your life you'd probably
steer away from this when you came out
of jail
for sure
sounds like you have a great mind and
you've learned a lot what's the most
important thing you've learned
most important thing i've learned um
i'm not really sure um
like i enjoy learning whatever it is um
reading is one of my biggest
hobbies um i still do that in my
addiction i like to write too
um
i like to journal or or create something
always i draw i like art a lot um
best thing i probably have learned is
is how to excel my my art skills i it's
it takes me that's the one thing that
still allows me to escape no matter what
it is i'm doing
um no matter what it is i'm dealing with
um my art allows me to to get away from
it
and not have to deal with it for that
that period of time
um
and i don't do art for anybody else
besides myself like i don't expect to
have a career out of it or anything it's
just something that i enjoy doing
um for me
and
i i mean that's my i love learning
anything there is to do with that'll
excel
or enhance my skills in art
i love to share it with anybody as well
um
that's my addiction your addictions
aren't the art that's what saves me all
the time
yeah my whole life
my whole life
because i probably fall into some of the
traps that all these people i interview
might have without it
yeah
i i don't want to be [ __ ]
some like this rich person or or anybody
big
like my goal is simply
to become
some of my my my kids
can look up to
um
i don't want to become a loser that i am
now
that my kids don't
i mean
my son's
he's going to be five
um on august 27th
and i mean he doesn't i'm still his hero
um
i mean i still have time to turn it
around
um he doesn't understand why
dad's not with him or dad
lives in a park
but
he's going to learn real fast
and i'm just going to become
the same person that my daughter looks
at this this loser that has nothing to
give
or that hasn't been there for her
birthdays
or christmases or
or in school to watch her graduate
or or anything good
she gets to
hear from me when i go to jail and i
give up my drug because i'm finally
clear-headed enough to call her
or a writer
am i i don't want that
for for myself or anybody
my family like that's not me
i've always been
the person that likes to surprise my
family with with something like good
like my mom's birthday is
i'll blow up hundreds of balloons and
leave it in the garage i'll go sneak
over to her house and put hundreds of
balloons in the garage when she goes to
work
she has to go through like
this lake of balloons
or
or building a bench that she's always
wanted or this is anything like i i love
to surprise my family with with things
that they don't ask for but
like they've hinted that they wanted and
and i've always been good at that
and i don't do that at all anymore
for my son's birthday the only income i
have is my general relief that i get
from um
from
the ebt i get food stamps and general
relief which is 221
and it's my son's birthday this this
month so as soon as i get my gr
i have to go spend it on my son and mail
it out to him
before
i use that money for my habit even if i
buy my my son presents and i don't mail
it out i'll go return the presents just
to support my habit if i don't take care
of it right away
like i have to use my money to get rid
of it
out of sight out of mind and then i
would support my habit just by any means
possible like i do
normally and is it that's sickening
221 is nothing
like it doesn't support me at all that
can barely gets me anything and i i
throw it away as soon as i get it on my
drugs
and it
i mean over my son's birthday it's just
sad
and that's how i treat everything
maybe it's not fair for my kid like on
christmas if if i don't
do anything to support to help myself
i have to use 221 dollars
to
from for my kid's birthday
i mean for christmas for my kids and
that's only because the only reason i
even have that
is because
the government gives it to me
if i didn't have that 221 dollars from
general relief i would i wouldn't even
i wouldn't do anything for my kids on
christmas
and it's [ __ ] sick
the people i love the most in life
aren't
as important as my drug
i get
everything comes second to it
everything
there's no way to live
that's hard
you deserve so much better thank you you
really do
appreciate that
hearing your voice
you